[Música]
Hola gracias por acompañarme en La
Crónica de medio ambiente soy María
Clara Calle Brasil es el país del mundo
donde más Defensores ambientales
asesinaron en la última década y México
lideró el ranking en 2021 mientras que
tres cuartas partes de todos los ataques
registrados en el mundo ocurrieron en
América Latina estos son los principales
hallazgos del informe anual que publica
la organización global witness el
reporte afirma que a medida que empeora
la crisis climática también aumenta la
violencia contra quienes defienden al
planeta y la mayoría de amenazas están
relacionadas con el conflicto de tierras
entre 2012 y 2021 fueron asesinados
1733 Defensores según global witness
Brasil es el país que encabeza el número
de homicidios seguido por Colombia
filipinas México y Honduras
solo contando las muertes del año pasado
México fue el país donde más Defensores
ambientales asesinaron y dentro de las
cinco naciones más violentas en 2021
también están Colombia Brasil filipinas
y Nicaragua en total el año pasado
mataron a 200 Defensores ambientales sin
embargo global witness advierte que esto
es una porción de Los homicidios Reales
Pues en muchos lugares falta información
ya sea por restricciones a la libertad
de prensa o porque el conflicto
dificulta monitorear la situación y la
violencia ha sido desproporcionada
contra los indígenas aunque los pueblos
étnicos representan solo el 5% de la
población mundial casi el 40% de todos
los ataques fue contra comunidades
indígenas esto ocurre por ejemplo en la
amazonía brasileña en Francia 24
conversamos con Andrea Carballo
investigadora de Human Rights watch
Brasil y quien lleva cinco años
reportando la crisis ambiental en ese
país esto nos dijo del riesgo de los
indígenas amazónicos
en realidad en los casos hemos visto una
ausencia de estado y un debilitamiento
de las agencias de protección ambiental
y de las agencias de protección de
derechos indígenas
violencia Entonces como son más
vulnerables los territorios son más
vulnerables a la invasión y también a la
violencia es un riesgo de impacto en el
ambiente donde ellos viven Incluso en
los departamentos los incendios afectan
muy fuertemente los medios de
subsistencia de esas poblaciones
de ser agredidos de ser amenazados las
personas comentan que las amenazas
llegan de una forma directa por medio de
pistoleros o por mensajes en redes
sociales la gente también habla de
agresiones físicas más propiamente
dichas y hasta asesinatos
en Brasil los ataques contra los
defensores ambientales
relacionados con el desmantelamiento de
instituciones como lo explicó Andrea
Carballo
pasó histórica
la situación históricamente siempre Fue
muy mala siempre la defensa del medio
ambiente generó procesos de retaliación
en los últimos años sobre todo en los 60
Vimos una explosión del desmantelamiento
y otras actividades ilegales acompañadas
y muy relacionadas con ese
debilitamiento y ausencia de estado
fueron muy infracticidas las agencias
ambientales en Brasil fueron muy
debilitadas y lo que escuchamos lo que
los defensores nos cuentan es que se
debilitamiento termina empoderando
aquellos que están destruyendo el medio
ambiente y también usando la violencia
contra ellos
global witness apunta que la impunidad
es la regla general en los homicidios
contra Defensores una impunidad que
también prima en Brasil
este trabajo de defensa de medio
ambiente y de la selva realmente tiene
un riesgo real de violencia y la gente
habla aquí de un contexto de impunidad
Porque esos casos de violencia raramente
son llevados a la justicia y las
infracciones ambientales relacionadas
con esa violencia tampoco son
responsabilizadas
entonces lo que pasa es que en la
práctica eso da vía libre para que las
organizaciones criminales continúen
trabajando en actividades ilegales Como
por ejemplo en la amazonia
otro país en el que también es peligroso
defender la tierra y el medio ambiente
es Colombia como nos lo contó Oscar
zampayo de la corporación yariguíes esta
organización está ubicada en Magdalena
medio una sub región que ha sido
impactada por la extracción de
hidrocarburos la ganadería la cría de
búfalos y la palma de aceite ser
defensor de los derechos humanos y de la
naturaleza en Colombia es demasiado
riesgoso esta profundización de la
extracción de hidrocarburos está
generando violaciones a los derechos
humanos de forma convencional es decir
las amenazas los atentados contra las
personas que cuestionan y denuncian las
pues las
derrames y las contaminaciones que
generan estas petroleras pero también
por la afectación que se genera la
naturaleza estamos observando en el
territorio del Magdalena medio altas
contaminaciones del agua del aire y de
la tierra producto de las
contaminaciones o producto de los
metales pesados o los desechos tóxicos
generados por la extracción de
hidrocarburos
al igual que en Brasil Óscar sostiene
que en Colombia faltan más acciones
institucionales para perseguir a los
responsables
hay una falta de actuación y de
diligencia por parte de las
instituciones del estado colombiano
principalmente en la fiscalía general de
la república que no genera unas
investigaciones oportunas e inmediatas
para evidenciar y Investigar la
situación continúa de de igual de
riesgosa hace cinco o seis años con el
agravante del recrudecimiento de los
hechos de violencia y con estas
historias llegamos al fin de la crónica
ambiental vean más en Francia
[Música]